two and a half hours I was just in the
car for it it was so funny about that
nothing yeah no it's actually it's
nothing it's not a single thing funny at
all it's hilarious to me because for me
it's like you time traveled like after
those two and a half hours like you have
rage you're not he's so angry oh no so
go on Google Maps before I leave and it
says hour and 40 minutes I'm like what
the [__] and it's not even letting me
take the way I'm I normally do it's not
even showing that way I was like that's
so weird and so I place a pin down
manually to see what the way I normally
would take and it's like 20 minutes
longer than the other way so like damn
that's crazy so then I select the other
way so I'm driving hour and a half later
I'm like this is not taking me to the
studio and I realized I had left the pin
placed and I didn't place it to work I
had to say out loud to myself it's okay
it's okay
it's okay two and a half hours I could
have went to [__] San Diego but
you're here Mexico right now you're here
in space with us
aren't you excited
no